three words to describe Oh lifting
tender I'm so excited it's gonna be the
best season yet I feel that way the
season six premiere of when calls the
heart is just weeks away and et has your
exclusive first look at the heart
melting onset photos it's gonna be like
a breath of fresh air
here's Elizabeth and little Jack the new
moms smiling ear-to-ear sweetly holding
her baby boy big blue eyes and a little
man face in his little baby body and
just really sweet precious yes looks
like little Jack is pretty popular
around Hope Valley folks can't seem to
stop staring at the adorable bundle of
joy including Lee and Bill it opens up
this whole other side of her character
and it really I think pays a lot of
omens to the character of Jack as well
because it's a reflection of him and I
think they have a baby now it was just a
new chapter in this sort of you know big
book of when calls are we're told baby
Jack will be a big focus this season as
Elizabeth leans on her friends for
support while balancing motherhood with
work describe what kind of mom she's
gonna be is she protective is she
relaxed oh I think that she's just
trying to make it all work she loves
this baby so deeply but she's also
trying to you know continue to continue
her teaching duties be a good friend and
so it said the juggle of all these
things that is hard and you know any mom
can relate to that I think but she is a
very affectionate and loving mother
there's two new guys in town Mountie
Nathan grant and salon owner Lucas
Bouchard of course they're both
attracted to Elizabeth she catches his
eye immediately okay as a person of
interest and but she's very very
reserved might potentially lead to
something down the road maybe a little
crossing every now
I know it's flirt you know there might
be some chemistry also in the romance
department Clara and Jessi will be
taking steps to secure their bond if you
build our barn over here
I'll burn while faith and Carson may be
heating up there's a lot of obstacles
for us to come together like what if it
goes bad this is like it's a small town
yeah and she's a great nurse so it's
like it's risking a really great working
relationships and then being in a small
town your that everyone's got their two
cents to add on the flip side we'll see
rosemary and Lea dealing with an
emotional issue that challenges their
relationship what we're seeing now with
rosemary in season six is this softer
more vulnerable side to her that we
haven't necessarily seen or explored in
much depth before we're seeing more of a
window into what that world is for her
when she doesn't have kind of like the
razzle-dazzle show being put on where
it's really more introspective when
calls the heart season six premieres
February 24th on Hallmark Channel I
think the fans will find joy in that
[Music]